[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
tom pelicero of the nfl network said
that the feeling within the coaches
subcommittee is officials have gotten
lacks on players going face to face
standing over people pointing fingers
etc they won't focus so much on
touchdown celebrations in this regard
but expect more flags to be thrown let's
start there with albert breer the senior
nfl reporter for the monday morning
quarterback he's been at the steelers
vikings packers bears lions colts browns
bengals niners cardinals chargers
cowboys rams raiders camps i should have
just said the camps you haven't been at
that might have been quicker there uh
this feels like it came out of nowhere
that we're now enforcing the taunting
rule here why
well it's it's not that unusual like i
think normally this time of year dan
they'll put out this video and this
video actually gets played for all the
players um within the 32 teams
and so the fact that we have this uh you
know this this rule clarification or
emphasis that sort of thing happens
every year
um and you know i i think it's probably
just to
um you know like tom they reported to
tone down some of the
like i guess confrontations on the field
that come from these sorts of things and
we saw it in the super bowl you know
tyron matthew and um and tom brady got
after each other
antoine winfield and uh and tyree kill
got after each other
and so you know i might my guess would
be and and i dig i need to dig into this
a little bit more my guess would be
um because they've like loosened the
rules on touchdown celebrations
um that maybe they feel like that's sort
of spilled over into celebrations of
other plays or
taunting and maybe they want to take
care of that um it's an emotional game
you know so i like i think you have to
let some stuff go but uh my guess would
be that the coaches here would probably
be looking to try to avoid the sort of
confrontations that we saw in the super
bowl yeah but i like those
confrontations i like them too i'm all
for them but uh i mean like it's good
for the drama i mean that's what we're
watching this is soap opera for guys
right that's sort of what football is
yes i like when it's not scripted i i
like when you get true emotion and and
usually the nfl plays to the fans like
what are the fans upset about what do
the fans want it feels like they
acquiesce i don't know if there was this
outcry from the fans saying we're tired
of seeing taunting the coaches might
feel like i've already got enough to
manage i don't want to have to manage my
player's behavior okay that's my guess
right
i've got enough problems out here like i
don't want to have to be getting on you
know my rookie defensive backhand fun
winfield for giving tyreek hill the
peace sign you know any other rule
changes that happened that maybe weren't
on the front burner
no i mean i
i'm just trying to think of like that i
mean like you know one that one to me
that i think's a bigger deal
um than people realize is that they
outlawed cut blocking outside of the
tackle box
um and i don't think people recognize
how common that is like outside zone
runs and then almost every screen pass i
mean how many screens have you seen
where there isn't someone a lineman
cutting a a linebacker or cutting a
defensive back
you know now if you eliminate some of
that like i think that could wind up
having a sneaky big impact just because
of the way those things are taught you
know
and look i think defensive players are
going to applaud this because you know
what every defensive player would tell
you is you've been protecting the
offensive players forever and here we
got people going after our knees you
know we have
like stuff happening under underneath
the pile
and you know i think defensive players
would applaud this but it's just as far
as like the flow of the game one that i
think slipped under the radar a little
bit this offseason would be that one
the the further outline of cut blocking
which i again i think is going to have
an effect on outside runs i think it's
also going to have a really big effect
on screens
maybe that's not the sexiest thing in
the world but i think there will be an
impact there the athletic had a column
the 25 most intriguing players for the
2021 nfl season
and even though this player who wasn't
on the list might not have a big impact
on the regular season i don't know if
there's a player under a more watchful
eye than jordan love because now he's
going to play all these preseason games
now we get to see just how good he is
and what that means for the possible
future if you're a packer fan and you
see progress there you might not be
holding on for dear life to aaron
rodgers that you might realize we do
have something here or oh my god we got
to hold on to aaron rodgers i is there
somebody who's more intriguing in the
pre-season
than jordan love in your well so think
so think about this dan all right so
last year no otas no mini camp they get
to training camp and really every coach
is
in the mode where we only have enough
practice time to get our starters ready
right backups don't really backup
quarterbacks don't really run the
offense during the season
so jordan love wasn't getting a lot of
reps in the summer because they're
getting aaron rodgers ready didn't
wasn't able to run the packers offense
much in the fall because he's running
the scout team
and then they get to the spring and i
had a coach there tell me that if they
ran 300 reps in otas and this is just
like a guesstimate they ran 300 reps in
the otas for the offense jordan love
took 270 of them so that nothing that's
above but that's across the first team
second team all those guys so you had
this guy from getting almost no reps and
they didn't feel like he was ready at
all coming out of last year which is one
of the reasons why they were so adamant
about holding on to aaron rodgers
and then they you had him drinking out
of a fire hose um in essence with rogers
gone in the spring so this is i'm with
you this is going to be fascinating
seeing how he looks and without question
you know this position the packers are
in after this year
where they're going to have aaron
rodgers going into a contract year
and they're going to have to make a
decision on what to do with him and he
could refuse to sign a deal and they
could be forced to trade him they could
extend him
all of that i think is colored by
what happens with jordan love and
you know the packers have spent the last
three four months trying to
get
like progress from jordan love and now i
think with these games they're going to
be looking to get answers on what jordan
love is and i think again like that
could have a massive impact on the way
that they approach next february march
the worst backup quarterback situation
is which team
jets maybe
um
you know i like how about a competitive
team
do you know who james morgan is the
biggest the jets
but a competitive team a competitive
team
um
if i was the rams i wouldn't feel
tremendous about what they've got behind
matthew stafford
are you confident with the cowboys
behind cowboys are the one though yeah i
mean you look at tenuchi
yeah if i was the cowboys like you
combine the fact that dak is coming off
of an injury
and you don't have much behind him
[Music]
and you didn't replace andy dalton
and
yeah i mean i think the cowboys are
right there because at least the rams
played their backup last year i mean ben
denucci got snaps but
i think i think a pro without like
taking a look at every single one of
them individually the cults
i think the the cowboys are there the
colts yeah so jacob but the thing is
like jacob easton at least had some
level of pedigree played big time
college football
um has skill like like skill sets fine
you know what i mean with him it's just
after the snap he doesn't see it very
well and i think that's part of why sam
ellinger got got some reps but at least
they've got a couple of guys they've
drafted that are in the pipeline like i
wouldn't
i think if you ask most teams they would
take
jacob beason over ben denucci just based
on talent because at least easton
there's a ceiling there and he played at
university of georgia he played the
university of washington
i think you know you'd feel more
comfortable about going into a game um
and this that's what this is really
about right like going into one game i
think you feel more comfortable going
into a game with jacob easton than you
would ben dinucci here's some good
situations the raiders have marcus
mariota browns have case keenum jags
with gardner minshew
uh the saints are going to have either
one of the other
yeah or jamis
and they could both be bad dolphins have
jacoby brissette
bears niners patriots with rookie
quarterbacks
i mean even blaine gabbert isn't
horrible right like that's fine i mean
you wouldn't want to be your starter but
they drafted kyle trask too right yeah
so like they've got like a you know
veteran guy and then a developmental guy
so they're okay chiefs have chad henny
see
geno smith
i mean those guys have experience you
know you're not gonna have
you know i mean like most teams aren't
gonna have like andy dalton as a backup
like the cowboys did last year and so i
mean having a guy you know like a jacoby
brissette or a geno smith
um how did the jets not have an
established backup quarterback who's not
non-threatening
and that's why i still think like i
still look at it
and i don't think nick foles wants to go
to the jets and maybe that's a factor in
this whole thing yeah but i think nick
foles would be perfect for the jets the
general manager there joe douglas
was with nick foles in philadelphia
and wouldn't you want zach wilson
beyonce's what you're saying like which
is the in case of emergency brake glass
thing wouldn't you want zach wilson to
have like a veteran guy in the room as
like a sounding board you know like the
guy who's been there and done it yeah
and like who can be a resource for him
right like you'd want to have somebody
like that in the room so
i'm with you i think that
i wouldn't be surprised that the jets
make a move to put somebody like that in
the room for zach wilson
it's great to catch up with you as
always uh the best
training camp stop that you had
was where and i'll tell you what like
watching the rams practice right now
i think i'm gonna pick the packers to
win the nfc but the rams have really
they really made me think about it i
mean i
it's just the way the operation runs
and the way matthew stafford looks
and just watching rahim morris as their
new defensive coordinator and watching
the way jalen ramsay is with his
teammates there's a really good vibe
there
and uh
can't beat the weather down there either
so okay we'll go with the rams give me
the team that you came away going uh oh
like uh oh like in a bad way yeah
it's so hard this time of year to say
that about anybody
um
the steelers offensive line
i would be concerned with
i would just like
that when i was there they had a rookie
at left tackle and dan moore a rookie at
center
i just be concerned about that offensive
line and i think the defense is going to
be really good is the defense going to
be like
like james ferry or troy palamalu james
harrison
carry the team good
i think at least for a little while
while they figure out the offensive line
they might need to be so that was the
one that really sort of stuck out to me
was that steelers offensive line and
mike tomlin always figures this stuff
out
that steelers offensive line would have
me pretty worried if i was there oh this
was brought up by one of our listeners
why are mike shanahan and mike holmgren
not in the hall of fame
i don't like mike shanahan to me should
be i mean if the hall of fame is about
like the story of pro football
and
like the impact you've had on pro
football
how many teams are running shanahan's
offense 25 years after
like he like because you remember what
it was like in 95 96 no one knew what to
do with that run game it basically
pumped life into john elway's career at
the very end
like that offense that went in 25 years
ago half the league's running it now
like people who don't like offensive
coaches who don't know it are trying to
get on staffs that run it so they can
learn it you know what i mean like
like how he won two super bowls
and then the impact that he had on
football overall
i like i don't know why he isn't and
holmgren
i think holmgren's there too he's went
to the super bowl with two different
teams and his coaching tree is
ridiculous like you look at those
packers staffs and the guys that were on
those staffs and steve mariucci and john
gruden and
like you go up and down the line like
both those guys at least deserve
consideration i think shanahan should be
in and i'm surprised he isn't and when i
look at like
bill cower and jimmy johnson all due
respect to those guys i think shanahan
is easily on those guys level yeah i do
too and i think you're going to look at
bill cower and and you're going to have
other coaches be compared to bill cower
so mike tomlin is already a hall of fame
coach in my opinion right right right
now if cowards in mike tomlin's going to
be in
yeah and i think you know
to me like
it's it's tough with coaches because i
think it's not just success it's like
legacy it's the impact you know what i
mean so it's not just
like tony dungy for example like the
impact that tony dungy had now tony
dungey only won one super bowl but tony
dungy's impact on football
um the first african-american coach to
win a super bowl the like amount of
assistance that he had that became
really good head coaches like
like i would i don't think you'd argue
tony don't use a hall of famer but it's
not about his overall record because
there are a lot of people who could
match his record it's tony dungy's
impact on the game of football
and
you know i i think that that's sort of
what you have to look at with some of
these coaches that's why i say with
shanahan like his impact is undeniable i
mean look across the league sean mcvay
his son
kyle in san francisco matt lafleur
arthur smith who
like never coached for him but was
influenced by him because he learned his
offense from lafleur like the branches
of his tree are all over the place and
so
i think you have to consider impact on
the game and that to me is like where
you separate the guys you know some guys
who've won one or two versus other guys
who have won one or two which you know
which ones are
which ones do you give entrance to the
hall of fame with the other coaches who
have won four super bowls you know the
guys like bill walsh and bill belichick
and chuck noll great to talk to you
albert thanks for joining us as always
all right thanks dan that's albert brier
senior nfl reporter for the monday
morning quarterback
he's good i always learn something when
he's on